you should watch intelligence if you
like
being the smartest person in your family
how would you describe intelligence to
someone who's never seen the show
so it's a workplace comedy with these
sort of real high stakes backdrop of
national security but within that we
have
your character uh who is an nsa agent
who joins a team and massively shakes
things up
in terms of the way they work because
he's got a lot more of a maverick
uh approach david how would you say
intelligence differs
from other workplace comedies it's an
ensemble show a workplace comedy
uh about a group of misfits right these
wonderful characters that co-workers but
the backdrop
is the high-stakes environment of where
they work
which is gchq um your the british
equivalent to our nsa at the same time
as
as uh as you've said they're talking
about you know planning
you know helen's birthday drinks or or
someone's retirement due and uh there's
a lot of
you know very the minutia of of the
office environment
i think that's the the biggest
difference although it's really um
it pays homage to the great i think
great workplace comedies
um that we both love how would you
describe my character
in three words pompous
ignorant and patriotic what about you
how would you describe my character in
three words lacking in intellect
thank you thanks for watching
don't forget to watch intelligence on
peacock and we'll see you at gchq
you